so michael let's start with you and
mayors for a guaranteed income how the
heck did this come about i know a little
bit of the backstory
um but would love to hear from you
exactly how you got started
a lot of it came as you partly from
watching just how
when you made the decision to run for
president primarily on this idea of a
guaranteed universal basic income how
much momentum from the
the idea attracted and seeing how you're
giving me too much credit michael
you're giving me too much credit you
were on this stuff before i arrived on
the scene
but but it was it it it made it very
clear how it was a national it was a the
nation was more ready for it than
many people i anticipated um so then
during covet 19
and sort of seeing how for the folks in
the stockton pilot which we launched in
february 2019 so many of them were
persisting because of this
500 that they were lucky to get
and how it allowed one lady who was
covet positive to take two weeks off for
work
they allowed another person who didn't
get access to unemployment benefits
a stable sort of income for three months
while they waited to get unemployment
rolls
and then the george floyd protests um
which we know
it's not just about police brutality but
about the violence of poverty the
violence of lack of opportunity
i think really had me go back to dr king
who was talking about a guaranteed
income
during a similar time this nation's
history when there was 253
riots across the nation of people who
are protesting and saying enough is
enough
well michael and i were on a panel what
was it two years ago now i guess the
your trial was just getting started
three years ago
three of 2017. no yeah it was october
2017.
i guess i believe you man time has flown
uh so we're in a panel about basic
income
and then you said to me after the panel
you said andrew you can say [ __ ] i could
never get away with saying
and i really took that to heart
michael's one of the things that
came through to me during the campaign
was that like we each have
a message and unfortunately or
fortunately
like the message and the messenger
really get tied up together
uh today in america you know it's like
like we could all be saying the same
thing and it would be
interpreted very very differently based
upon uh who
we are thank you for listening in i hope
you enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you